speaking of interviews how was your
interview style similar to your father's
and how is it different I really pride
myself on my research the same as my dad
did my dad had an amazing system he of
how he compiled information about his
subjects he would read all four New York
newspapers every day and all the
magazines from people to time in life
and Entertainment Weekly and he would
just rip out articles on different
actors if someone was written about in
the New York Times he ripped it out he
would send it to a friend of our
families in Portland Oregon who would
file all of the clippings by name and
then when my dad would sit down with
Andy Garcia he would send him the Andy
Garcia folder that had ten years of
clippings in it now I have the internet
so I don't have to rip out random
articles or the my reading of newspapers
but the internet is tricky so you never
know what's a hundred percent on there
and it's also everybody has it now you
know everybody has access to it now so I
really pride myself on research and
consuming as much of a subjects material
as possible today I'm interviewing
Penelope Cruz and before you guys
Kaitlyn in here I was on the internet
looking up old Penelope Cruz interviews
I just watched a piece she did with
Charlie Rose and she spoke at length
about her love of dancing when she was a
child so I can come in and maybe ask her
something about that cuz you're now
these movies they're doing so many
interviews sometimes you're you know
your interview number 68 out of 350 so
how do you stand out how do you have
that one little nugget that lets them
know okay you came prepared I'm gonna be
a little bit more present in this
interview and you see with you mentioned
I cover a lot of these studio movies I
just went to London to cover Snow White
and the Huntsman Charlize probably does
I don't know five thousand interviews
over the course of you know six months
promoting that movie from comic-con and
WonderCon to show West you know to to
all these different events over then
premieres all over the world we're
talking about travel you know when these
big movies rolled out they do premieres
and every
the globe so how do you do how do you
stand out when you're one of five
thousand interviews and it's by doing
your homework it's by maybe referencing
an older movie they've done that you've
stayed up at you know and watch late one
night maybe it's referencing an
interview that they did that you saw
them do and just something they get them
to kind of break out of the mold a
little bit so that that's where I relate
to my dad my dad really instilled that
in me early and I saw it firsthand with
his crazy process and I saw how it paid
off when you pulled out that little
nugget that had people kind of surprised
it really warms them up to you and gives
you a better interview and I think we're
different in the sense of he never
really he never worked for these types
of outlets he covered for more
traditional hard news outlets you know
he worked at NBC in New York for many
years in Channel 11 in New York and and
I'm working in more the celebrity space
so sometimes my interviews are a little
bit more lighthearted a little bit more
fun and Goofy and Russell Brand came to
our offices at the e channel once and
gave me an entire makeover and in the
nail polish and the hair thought that
hold the skinny jeans and the whole
thing you know they're just I saw I feel
like I have I'm playing to a different
kind of audience than my dad has over
the years and so you kind of keep that
in mind when you conduct your interviews
when you talk about how your interviews
are fun and light-hearted what about the
rare instance and no names involved but
where someone becomes a little combative
and maybe it's nothing you've done maybe
it's their own issue is there a way that
you can kind of smooth things out and
still keep the cameras rolling I'll give
you a good story for that happened with
me and Jamie Foxx on a movie on jarhead
my reason I'm moving Jake Gyllenhaal and
and Peter Sarsgaard and and Jamie was
just some real Jamie Foxx mode yeah the
sunglasses on he was on his phone I was
asking questions he was talking to his
friend
I said listen Jamie I have a 70 I have a
79 Brougham outside that's a reference
to the type of car that they drove in
the great white hype which he had a
supporting role
I don't was 79 or 70 whatever it was I
just mentioned the car from the great
white hype and he paused
took the sunglasses off put the phone
down it was like alright let's do an
interview and if you just again pull out
that little nugget that shows you've
done your homework and you're a
professional and you're there to you
know help them promote their movie and
ask them intelligent questions they
usually respond but oftentimes that you
know a lot of people in my position
don't remember that the people there
sitting opposite from our people they've
got real in their life they haven't
broke up with their girlfriend last
night or their mom is sick or they have
a painter coming to redo their kitchen
and they have it there are the real
people so you talk to them they're like
like they're real people and they
usually respond in an unpleasant way I
found that sometimes some of my
colleagues will go in and kind of treat
them as soundbites and not respect that
they have a private life or our personal
life and I don't know Woody Allen movie
last night it was interesting that the
Roberto Benigni 's character is a
middle-class guy in in Rome and all of a
sudden he walks out of his apartment and
there's 200 paparazzi taking pictures of
him and asking him the most innocuous
mundane questions of what did you eat
for breakfast this morning and he's like
I had some toast just showing that he's
a real person but why we put these
people up on pedestals sometimes we
treat them differently and I think it's
important that yes someone's insanely
talented are beautiful or amazing at
their craft but they're a real person so
talk to Christopher Nolan yes he's a
genius as a filmmaker but talk to him
like he's a normal guy and he'll respond
in a way that's rather candid as opposed
to giving you the kind of regular
soundbite if you owe
you